hello and welcome to domain 4 of the
cissp certification course offered by
simplylearn
this domain provides an introduction to
the communications and network security
let us explore the objectives of this
domain in the next screen after
completing this domain you will be able
to
describe the various secure network
architectures and designs
recognize the importance of securing
network components
list the different secure communication
channels list the common network attacks
and of the countermeasures
let us begin with the scenario
highlighting the importance of
communication and network security in
the next stream who is preparing for his
cissp exam
read an internal case file on a recent
spam attack on nutri worldwide inc
at the minnesota plant a vendor who had
visited the plant used his laptop to
complete a few transactions
he connected to the wireless after
taking approvals
he used his flash drive to take backup
of the transactions
the flash drive had viruses and these
entered the network through his laptop
causing the local server to crash
this had far-reaching effects
in the next screen
we will focus on the introduction to
secure network architecture and disease
communication protocols define
communication
the protocols can be grouped into stacks
family or
suite there are two most popular models
osi and tcpip models
both the models divide communication
into different layers
each layer addresses specific
requirements of the communication
process security can be addressed more
efficiently using the layers now discuss
the osi reference model
international organization for
standardization iso created the open
systems interconnection osi reference
model in the early 1980s
the purpose was to help vendors create
interoperable network devices
osi is a standard model for network
communications which allows dissimilar
networks to communicate
the osi reference model describes how
data and network information are
communicated from one computer to
another computer through a network media
the osi reference model breaks this
approach in the seven distinct layers
also called the protocol stack
layering divides a piece of data into
functional groups that permit an easy
understanding of each piece of data
mapping each protocol to the model is
useful for comparing protocols
each layer has unique set of properties
and directly interacts with its adjacent
layers
in the process of data encapsulation
data from one layer is wrapped around a
data packet from an adjoining layer
each layer on one workstation
communicates with its respective layer
on another workstation using protocols
that are agreed upon communication
formats
the following chart describes the osi
reference model
please do not take salesperson advice
can be used as the mnemonic phase to
remember each layer of the osi model
physical layer
at this layer bits from the data link
layer are converted into electrical
signals and transmitted on a physical
data link layer
this layer prepares the packet it
receives from the network layer to be
transmitted as frames on the network
network layer
this layer provides switching and
routing technologies creating logical
paths known as virtual circuits for
transmitting data from node to node
the functions of this layer are routing
and forwarding addressing internet
working error handling congestion
controlling and packet
sequencing transport layer
this layer provides transparent transfer
of data between in systems or hosts and
is responsible for end-to-end error
recovery and flow control
it ensures complete data transfer
session layer
this layer establishes manages and
terminates connections between
applications
the session layer sets up coordinates
and terminates conversations exchanges
and dialogues between the applications
at each end
it deals with session and connection
coordination
presentation layer
this layer provides independence from
difference in data representation as is
encryption by translating from
application to network format and vice
versa
the presentation layer works to
transform data into the form that the
application layer can accept
this layer formats and encrypts data to
be sent across a network providing
freedom from compatibility problems
it is also called the syntax layer
application layer
this layer supports application and end
user processes
communication partners are identified
quality of service is identified
user authentication and privacy are
considered and any constraints on data
syntax are identified
everything at this layer is application
specific
this layer provides application services
for file transfers email and other
network software services
telnet and ftp are applications that
exist entirely in the application level
tiered application architectures are a
part of this layer let's now understand
the working of the osi model
data is sent from a source to a
destination computer
in a layered architecture model the data
passes down through each layer from the
highest application layer layer 7 and
the osi model to the lowest layer
physical layer layer 1 of the osi model
of the source
it is then transmitted across the medium
cable and is received by the destination
computer where it passes to the layers
in the opposite direction from the
lowest layer 1 to the highest layer 7.
each protocol operates at specific
layers
each protocol in the source computer has
a job allocated
they are responsible for attaching its
own unique information to the data
packet when it comes to its layer
when the data packet reaches the
destination computer it moves up the
model
each protocol detaches and examines only
the data that was attached by its
protocol counterpart at the source
computer
then it sends the rest of the packet up
the protocol stack to the next highest
layer
each layer at the individual destination
sees and deals only with the data that
was packaged by its counterpart on the
sending now i'll learn about each layer
of the osi model in detail the first
layer is the physical layer
this layer defines the physical
connection between a computer and a
network and converts the bits into
voltages or light impulses for
transmission
it also defines the electrical and
mechanical aspects of the device's
interface to a physical transmission
medium such as twisted pair coaxial or
fiber optic
communications hardware and software
drivers as well as electrical
specifications are found in this layer
the physical layer has only two
responsibilities
firstly it sends bits and receive bits
signal regeneration and repeating is
primarily a physical layer function
secondly it defines standard interfaces
such as rs232
and rs449
x.21
and high-speed serial interface hssi
examples of physical layer are eia-232
or rs232 and synchronous optical network
sonet the physical layer provides
services to the data second layer is the
data link layer
this layer defines the protocol that
computers must follow in order to access
the network for transmitting and
receiving messages
token ring and ethernet operate within
this layer
this layer establishes the
communications link between individual
devices over a physical link or channel
it also ensures that messages are
delivered to the proper device and
translates the messages from layers
above into bits for the physical layer
to transmit
it also formats the message into data
frames and adds a customized header that
contains the hardware destination and
source address
the data link layer contains the logical
link control sub-layer and the media
access control mac sub-layer
mac controls the way a system on the
network gains access to the data and
permission to transmit it llc controls
frame synchronization error check and
flow
bridging is a data link layer function
examples of data link layer protocols
are address resolution protocol arp
serial line internet protocol slip
point-to-point protocol ppp etc
the data link layer uses services
provided by the physical layer and
provides services to the network layer
is the network layer
this layer defines how the small packets
of data are routed and relayed between
in systems on the same network or on
interconnected networks at this layer
message routing error detection and
control of node data traffic are managed
the network layer's primary function is
to send packets from the source network
to the destination network therefore the
network layer is primarily responsible
for routing
examples of network layer protocols are
internet protocol ip
open shortest path first ospf
internet control message protocol
icmp
and routing information protocol rip
the network layer uses services provided
by the data link layer and provide
services to the transport layer as the
transport layer
this layer defines how to address the
physical locations and devices on the
network
how to make connections between nodes
and how to handle the networking of
messages it is responsible for
maintaining the end and integrity and
control of the session
services located in the transport layer
both segment and reassemble the data
from upper layer applications and united
with the same data stream which provides
end-to-end data transport services
it establishes a logical connection
between the sending host and destination
host on a network
the transport layer is also responsible
for providing mechanisms for
multiplexing upper layer applications
session establishment and the teardown
of virtual circuits
examples of transport layer protocols
are transmission control protocol tcp
and user datagram protocol
udp the transport layer uses services
provided by the network layer and
provides services to the session layer
is the session layer
this layer makes the initial contact
with other computers and sets up the
lines of communication
it formats the data for transfer between
end nodes provides session restart and
recovery and performs the general
maintenance of the session from end to
end
the session layer offers three different
modes simplex half duplex and full
duplex
it also splits up a communication
session into three different phases such
as connection establishment data
transfer and connection release
some examples of session layer protocols
are network file system nfs
structured query language sql and remote
procedure call rpc
the session layer uses services provided
by the transport layer and provides
services to the presentation layer is
the presentation layer this layer
presents data to the application layer
it functions as a translator such as
extended binary coded decimal
interchange code ebc dic
or american standard code for
information exchange
ascii
tasks such as data compression
decompression encryption and decryption
are all associated with this layer
this layer defines how the applications
can enter a network
while surfing the web it is most likely
to encounter some of the following
presentation layer standards such as
hypertext transfer protocol http
tagged image file format tiff
a standard graphics format joint
photographic experts group jpeg
also a standard for graphics defined by
the joint photographic experts group
musical instrument digital interface
midi
a format used for digitized music and
motion picture experts group mpeg
the motion picture experts group is
standard for the compression and coding
of motion video
the presentation layer uses services
provided by the session layer and
provides services to the application
layer is the application layer
this layer supports the components that
deal with the communication aspects of
an application
the application layer is responsible for
identifying and establishing the
availability of the intended
communication partner
it is also responsible for determining
whether sufficient resources exist for
the intended communication
this layer is the highest level and is
the interface to the user
some of the examples of application
layer applications are world wide web
www
file transfer protocol ftp
trivial file transfer protocol tftp
line printer daemon lpd
and simple mail transfer protocol sms
discuss the transmission control
protocol internet protocol tcp in this
screen
transmission control protocol internet
protocol tcpip
is a common name for the suite of
protocols originally developed by the
department of defense dod in the 1970s
to support the construction of the
internet
the internet is based on tcpip which is
named after the two best-known protocols
in the suite
a cissp candidate should be familiar
with the major properties of tcpip and
should know which protocols operate at
which layers of the tcpip protocol suite
the tcp model consists of four layers
the network access layer which controls
the hardware devices and media that make
up the network
the internet layer that determines the
best path to the network
the transport layer which supports
communication between diverse devices
across diverse networks
the application layer which represents
data to the user plus encoding and
dialog control
the next screen will focus on tcp model
types of tcp layers are network access
layer internet layer
host a host layer and application layer
at the end of the tcp model the network
access layer monitors the data exchange
between the host and the network
this layer is equivalent to the data
link and physical layers of the osi
model it oversees hardware addressing
and defines protocols for the physical
transmission of data
example wi-fi ethernet token ring atm
and ppp
the internet layer corresponds to the
osi network layer it designates the
protocols relating to the logical
transmission of packets over the network
it gives network nodes an ip address and
handles the routing of packets among
multiple networks
it also controls the communication flow
between hosts
the primary internet layer protocols are
internet protocol ip
address resolution protocol arp
reverse address resolution protocol rarp
and internet control message protocol
i see the host layer is similar to the
osi transport layer
it defines protocols for setting up the
level of transmission service
it provides for reliable end-to-end
communications
ensures the error-free delivery of the
data
handles packet sequencing of the data
and maintains the integrity of the data
the primary host to host layer protocols
are transmission control protocol tcp
and user datagram protocol udp the
application layer is exactly the tcp
it is made up of everything that the
application is trying to communicate
using tcp
tcp
views everything above the three bottom
layers as the responsibility of the
application so that the application
presentation and session layers of the
osi model are considered folded into
this top layer
therefore the tcpip suite primarily
operates in the transport and network
layers of the osi model
http ftp and smtp are some of the
example protocols
in the next screen we will look into the
comparison of osi and tcp pip model is
very similar to the osi model however
with fewer layers
the network interface layer provides
physical communication and routing
within a network
it corresponds to everything required to
implement an ethernet
it is sometimes described as two layers
a physical layer and a link layer
in terms of the osi model it covers
layers one and two
the internet layer includes everything
that is required to move data between
networks
it corresponds to the ip protocol but
also to internet control message
protocol icmp and internet group
management protocol igmp
in terms of the osi model it corresponds
to layer 3.
the host to host transport layer
includes everything required to move
data between applications it corresponds
to tcp and udp
in terms of the osi model it corresponds
to layer four
the application layer covers everything
specific to a session or application in
other words everything related to the
data payload
in terms of the osi model it corresponds
to layers 5 through 7.
owing to its core structure it is not
well suited to describe application
level information exchange all hosts on
the internet have a logical and
numerical id called an internet protocol
ip address
on the internet or any network using ip
each data packet is assigned an ip
address of the sender and the recipient
each device receives a packet and makes
routing decisions based on the packet's
destination i p address
i p addressing provides an unreliable
datagram service
this means it does not guarantee that
the package will be delivered at all
delivered only once or even delivered in
the order in which it was sent
ipaddress has two parts network and host
a subnet mask is used to distinguish
between the network and host portions in
an ip address
now let us look at the different types
of ip address versions of the ipn use
ipv4
ipv4 and ipv6 ipv6
each version explains an ip address
differently
ipv4 and ipv6 are designed not to be
interoperable
ipv4 or internet protocol version 4 is a
simple form of network addressing
designed to carry data across networks
it is connectionless and unreliable and
provides best effort packet delivery
if it requires connections or
reliability it has to be provided by a
higher level protocol carried by ip such
as the transmission control protocol or
tcp
network addresses in ipv4 are 32 bits in
length and are expressed as a dot
decimal notation that is xx dot xx dot
xx
where the range of each xx is 0 to 255
decimal
a 32-bit address field allows 2 to the
power 32 or nearly 4.3 billion addresses
example of a typical ipv4 network
address is 192.168.0
the availability of ipv4 addresses in a
world where humans and their devices
outnumber them became a major problem
this led to the creation of ipv6 which
uses
bit addresses the new address space
provides the potential for a maximum of
2 to the power 128 or about 3.403
by 10 to the power 38 addresses
ipv6 became more predominant since the
release of microsoft vista and windows 7
operating systems
these operating systems support ipv6 and
have it enabled by default
most modern linux operating systems such
as ubuntu are also by default ipv6
enabled
ipv6 addresses are represented as eight
groups of four hexadecimal digits
separated by colons
example of a typical ivp6 network
address is fe80 colon zero zero zero
zero colon zero zero zero zero colon
zero zero zero zero colon
zero two zero two colon
b three f f colon
fe1e colon
the main intent of this addressing is
not just to provide an adequate quantity
of addresses but to allow an effective
combination of sub-network routing
prefixes at the writing note let us
discuss classful i p addressing
originally the entire available ip
address space was divided into two parts
the network number that consists of the
first eight bits of an ip address
the host address that consists of the
remaining 24 bits
this resulted in only 256 possible
networks in the entire internet which
was not feasible thus the concept of
classful networks was introduced which
resulted in a greater number of smaller
networks
there are five types of classful ip
addressing class a
b
c
d and e class a network consists of an 8
bit network address and a 24 bit host
address ip ranges from 0.0.0.0
to 126.255.255.255.
and implied netmask is 255.0.0.0
thus class a network could contain 1677
214 nodes
126 such networks were created for a
large organization network consists of a
16-bit network address and a 16-bit host
address
ip ranges from 128.0.0.0
to 191.255.255.255.
and implied mass is 255.255.0.0
each network could contain
65534 nodes
16382 of such networks for 3d network
consist of a 24-bit network address and
an 8-bit host address
ip ranges from 192.0.0.0
to 223.255.255.255.
and implied net mass is 255.255.255.0
thus classy network could contain 254
nodes
over two million such networks with the
network is reserved for multicast
ip ranges from 224.0.0.0
to 239.255.255.255.
class e network is reserved for research
purposes
it ranges from 240.0.0.0
to 255.255.255.255.
in the next screen we will discuss the
classes interdomain routes interdomain
routing cidr be discussed in this screen
the scheme of classful networks lived
for a short term
this gave rise to cidr
cidr is a method for allocating ip
addresses and routing internet protocol
packets the internet engineering task
force introduced cidr in 1993 to replace
the previous addressing architecture of
classical network design on the internet
the goal of cidr was to slow the growth
of routing tables on routers across the
internet
and to help slow the rapid exhaustion of
ipv4 addresses
ip addresses consist of two groups of
bits in the address
the most significant bits are the
network address which identifies a whole
network or subnet and the least
significant set forms the host
identifier which specifies a particular
interface of a host on that network
the process of dividing a network into
two or more networks is called
subnetting
a subnet is a logical invisible unit of
an ip network
a subnet mask determines which ip
address a subnet belongs to
cidr disposed the rigid scheme of class
a b and c networks and permitted the
creation of subnet mask of any length
called a variable link subnet mask or
vlsm from 8 bits to 31 bits
this permitted internet service
providers isps to allocate small
networks to customers that did not
require more than a few addresses
the introduction of cidr led to more
efficient allocation of available ip
addresses on the internet
this division is used as the basis of
traffic routing between ip networks and
for address allocation policies
classical network design for ipv4 signs
the network address as one or more 8-bit
groups resulting in the blocks of class
a b or c addresses classless inter
domain routing allocates address space
to internet service providers and end
users on any address bit boundary
instead of on 8-bit segments in ipv6
however the interface identifier has a
fixed size of 64 bits by convention and
smaller subnets are never allocated to
end users
cidr notation is a syntax of specifying
ip addresses and their associated
writing prefix it appends a slash
character to the address and the decimal
number of leading bits to the routing
prefix eg 192.168.1.3
23 for ipv4
and 2001 colon db8 double colon
discuss private networks and loopback
address in this screen
not all the network addresses are
available for general use
some address blocks that are reserved
include private networks and loot back
addresses
private network allows accessing a guest
machine by an address not publicly
accessible from the global internet
organizations are encouraged to assign
private network ip addresses to nodes in
its internal networks
it can then utilize network address
translation nat at its border routers to
translate those private network
addresses into one of its allocated
addresses
the address blocks reserved for private
network are
10.0.0.0
to 10.255.255.255.
172.16.0.0
to 172.31.255.255.
192.168.0.0
to 192.168.
the image shows the ip packets network
address translation where the private
address is translated to public address
and vice versa at boundary routers
lootback address is a special address
127.0.0.1
to 127.0.0.255
used to signify a node's own address
as shown in the image loopback addresses
127.0.0.1
point back to the issuing computer let's
look at the different types of ip
addressing
the internet layer provides different
addressing types that will result in
messages sent to one or more destination
nodes
they are unicast anycast
multicast and broadcast
the unicast addressing type is the most
common type of addressing where a packet
is sent to a single i p address
destination
any cast address type is where a packet
is sent only to one of the groups of
nodes whichever is closest or most
available
multicast address type is where a packet
is sent to a group of receiving nodes on
different networks
a packet is sent to a multicast address
in the range of 224.0.0.0
to 239.255.255.255.
it is also sent to the routers and the
network track recipients
it propagates packets to destinations as
needed broadcast address type is where a
packet is sent to a networks broadcast
address which causes the packet to be
sent to all nodes on a network
dynamic host configuration protocol dhcp
and address resolution protocol arp
utilize broadcast nodes now discuss
routed and routing protocols
routers use router to router
communication protocol to determine the
most efficient network routes between
two nodes on a network
they help routers in making good routing
decisions making the right choice about
which way to forward packets routed
protocol is a protocol which provides
enough information in its network layer
address to allow the packet to reach its
destination
ip and ipx are the examples of routed
protocol
routing protocol is a protocol used by
routers to share routing information for
example routing information protocol rip
is one of the earliest routing protocols
the rip uses hop count as a primary
routing metric
fewer the number of hops for a given
destination
more favorite a destination will be
regardless of the actual link speeds
involved
the maximum number of hops supported by
rip is 15 which seemed adequate when it
was invented in the 1970s
however this limitation is one of
several reasons why rip has given way to
more scalable and reliable protocols
such as ospf and isis
rip runs over the udp protocol on port
cisco's proprietary interior gateway
routing protocol
igrp was developed to overcome the
limitations of rip its only routing
metric was hot count
igrp supports multiple metrics
bandwidth delay
load mtu and reliability
igrp's maximum hop count is 255
igrp was replaced by eigrp
igrp does not use tcp or udp but runs
directly over ip
it is used by routers to exchange
routing data within an autonomous system
are the types of network protocols
transmission control protocol
user datagram protocol
internet protocol
address resolution protocol and internet
control message protocol icmp mission
control protocol tcp provides a complete
duplex and reliable connection
the incoming tcp packets are sequenced
to match the original transmission
sequence numbers
any lost or damaged packets are
re-transmitted
tcp is costly in terms of network
overhead and is slower than udp
reliable data transport is addressed by
tcp to ensure the following goals are
achieved
an acknowledgement is sent back to the
sender on the reception of delivered
segments
any unacknowledged segments are
retransmitted
segments are sequenced back in their
proper order on arrival at their
destination
a manageable data flow is maintained in
order to avoid congestion overloading
and data loss
port types are reserved for well-known
ports 0 to 1023
registered ports 1024-49-151
and dynamic ports 49 152 to 65 535
examples include http
ftp
is similar to tcp however it gives only
best effort delivery which means it
offers no error correction
does not sequence the packet segments
and does not care in which order the
packet segments arrive at their
destination
it is referred to as an unreliable
protocol
udp does not create a virtual circuit
and does not contact the destination
before delivering the data thus it is
considered a connectionless protocol
udp imposes less overhead which makes it
faster than tcp
this is for applications that can afford
to lose a packet now and then such as
streaming video or audio
examples include dns
tftp and protocol is a network layer
protocol which handles addressing and
routing
ip specifies the packet format of
datagrams and the addressing scheme
there are two types of ip versions
ipv4 32-bit addresses and ipv6
128 address protocol needs to know the
hardware address of the package
destination so we can send the packet
arp is used to match an ip address to a
media access control mac address arp
allows the 32-bit ip address to be
matched with this hardware address
a mac address is a 6 byte 12-digit
hexadecimal number subdivided into two
parts
the first three bytes of first half of
the mac address is the manufacturer's
identifier
this can be a good troubleshooting aid
if a network device is malfunctioning
because it will isolate the brand of the
failing device
the second half of the mac address is
the serial number the manufacturer has
assigned to the device
arp interrogates the network by sending
out broadcast seeking a network node
that has a specific ip address and then
asking it to reply with its hardware
address
arp maintains a dynamic table known as
the arp cache of the translations
between ip addresses and mac addresses
so that it has to broadcast a request to
every host only the first time it is
needed
in some cases the mac address is known
but the i p address needs to be
discovered
it is sometimes the case when disclosed
machines are booted onto the network
using reverse address resolution
protocol rarp
the machine sends out a packet that
includes its mac address along with the
request to be informed of which ip
address should be assigned to that mac
address
an rarp server responds with the control
message protocol icmp is a management
protocol and messaging service provider
for ip
icmp's primary function is to send
messages between network devices
regarding the health of the network it
can inform host a better route to a
destination if there is trouble with an
existing route and it can help identify
the problem with the route
ping is an icmp utility used to check
the physical connectivity of machines on
a network ttp works on application layer
or layer 7 and is the foundation of data
communication for the world wide web www
it is a stateless protocol used to
exchange or transfer hypertext
http is mapped to tcp port 80.
http has a simple access control and
authentication mechanism
it does not support encryption
the access control and authentication is
carried out through an extensible set of
challenge response authentication
schemes which can be used by a server to
challenge a client request and by a
client to provide authentication
information
let us now discuss how http proxying can
be used as a security measure with http
an http proxy is a server that receives
requests from a user's web browser and
makes the request to the internet on
behalf of the user
http proxying hides the information of
the internal network from the public
network
open proxy servers allow unrestricted
access to get commands from the internet
they can be used as stepping stones for
launching attacks or to obscure the
origin of illegitimate requests
an open proxy server bears an inherent
risk of opening access to protected
internet pages from the internet
anonymizing proxies provide security and
allow anonymization of http requests
since http transmits the data in clear
text it creates several logging
information on web servers and proxy
servers which can be a security issue if
an unauthorized person gets access to it
content filtering prevents users from
downloading unwanted content
it also prevents access to unauthorized
services
let us discuss the implications of
multi-layer protocols in the following
screen transmission control protocol or
internet protocol
or tcp slash ip protocol suite consists
of various layers with many individual
protocols and is also known as
multi-layer protocol
using multi-layer protocol encryption
can be incorporated on various layers
it gives added security
the higher layers support wide range of
protocols the security practitioner can
make use of appropriate protocol from
the pool of available protocols
use of multi-layer protocols can give
rise to vulnerabilities
the security filters can be evaded by
manipulating the use of protocols
there can be issues of covert channels
that give unauthorized access to the
system or can cause information
disclosure
in the next screen we will discuss
distributed network
process automation systems different
components communicate with each other
using a set of communication protocols
known as dnp3 or distributed network
protocol
it was developed for communications
between various types of data
acquisition and control equipment
it is commonly used in electric and
water companies
one of the examples of systems using
dnp3 is supervisory control and data
acquisition or scada it is a system
operating with coded signals over
communication channels to provide
control of remote equipment
it is a centralized system that monitors
and controls entire sites or complexes
of systems spread over large areas
scada uses many different communication
methods which include wide area networks
or wands networking devices and modems
it is used for communication between a
master station and remote terminal units
or rtus or intelligent electronic
devices or ieds
let us discuss the lan or network
technologies in the next screen three
types of lan network technologies
ethernet token ring and fiber
distributed data interface fddi
ethernet defined in ieee 802.3 played a
major role in the rapid spread of lands
in the 1980s
the architecture was flexible relatively
inexpensive and it was easy to add and
remove devices from the land
it is the most popular land architecture
the physical topologies that are
supported by ethernet are bus
star and point-to-point however the
logical topology is the bus
with the exception of full duplex
ethernet which does not have the issues
of collisions the architecture uses csma
cd
this protocol allows devices to transmit
data with a minimum of overhead compared
to token ring resulting in an efficient
use of bandwidth
because devices must retransmit when
more than one device attempts to send
data on the medium
too many re-transmissions due to
collisions can cause serious amount of
degradation
the ethernet standard supports coaxial
cable
unshielded twisted pair and fiber optics
ethernet was originally rated at 10 mbps
however with 10 megabyte disk drives
users quickly figured out how to use and
exceed its capacity to meet the growing
demand for more bandwidth 100 base tx
100 mbps over twisted pair and 100 based
fx
100 mbps over multi-mode fiber optics
were created
when the demand grew for even more
bandwidth over unshielded twisted pair
1000 base t was defined and 1000 base sx
and 1000 base lx were defined for fiber
optics
these standards support 1000 mbps
ibm originally designed token ring ieee
802.5
token ring was adapted with some
modification by the ieee as ieee 802.5
despite the architecture's name token
ring uses a physical star topology
the logical topology however is a ring
each device receives data from its
upstream neighbor and transmits to its
downstream neighbor
token ring uses ring passing to mediate
which device may transmit
a special frame called a token is passed
on the land
to transmit a device must possess the
token
to transmit on the lan the device
appends data to the token and sends it
to its next downstream neighbor
devices retransmit frames whenever the
token is not the intended recipient
when the destination device receives a
frame it copies the data marks the frame
as read and sends it to its downstream
neighbor
when the packet returns to the source
device it confirms that the packet has
been read
it then removes the frame from the ring
token ring is now considered a legacy
technology that is rarely seen and only
then because there has been no reason to
upgrade away from it
token ring has almost entirely been
replaced with ethernet technology
fddi is a token passing architecture
that uses two rings
since fddi employs fiber optics fddi was
designed to be a 100 mbps network
backbone
only one ring the primary is used the
other ring secondary is used as a backup
information in the rings flows in
opposite directions from each other
hence the rings are referred to as
counter rotating if a break or outage
occurs the ring will then wrap back the
other direction keeping the ring intact
fddi is not considered a legacy
technology and has been supplanted by
more modern transport technologies
initially asynchronous transfer mode atm
but more recently multi-protocol label
switching mpls
like token ring fddi is a token passing
media access topology
the major advantage of fddi is that it
operates over long distances with high
speeds and less electromagnetic or radio
frequency interference
let us begin with transmission media
transmission media is used for
transmitting data from a source to a
destination
classes of transmission media includes
conducted or guided media and wireless
or unguided media
types of transmission media include
unshielded twisted pair
shielded twisted pair
coaxial cable and fiber optic cable
in the next screen we will discuss the
types of transmission air cabling is a
relatively low speed transmission medium
consisting of two insulated wires
arranged in a regular spiral pattern
the wires can be shielded stp or
unshielded utp
stp cable is shielded therefore it has
better electromagnetic interference emi
immunity
utp cabling is a four pair wire medium
used in a variety of networks it does
not require the thick spacing between
connections that is necessary with
coaxial type connections
it is unshielded therefore is more
susceptible to emi and crosstalk
utp comes in several categories
the category rating is based on how
tightly the copper cable is wound within
the shielding
they are
category 1 used for telephone
communications and not suitable for
transmitting data
category 2 specified in the eia tia 586
standard to be capable of handling data
rates up to 4 million bits per second in
bps
category 3
used in 10 base t networks and specified
to be capable of handling data rates of
up to 10 mbps
category 4
used in token ring networks and able to
transmit data at speeds of up to 16 mbps
category 5
consists of 4 twisted pairs in a single
jacket
maximum length is 100 meters
suitable for 100 megabits and can be
used for gigabit ethernet
category 6
backward compatible with category 5 and
5e
higher specifications for noise and
crosstalk
suitable for gigabit ethernet
maximum cable length is 100 meters
category 7
more stringent than category 6 cabling
cat 7 is suitable for 10 gigabit
networks
maximum length is 100 outer cylindrical
conductor of a coaxial cable surrounds a
single inner wire conductor
it needs repeaters in every 200 to 500
meters and works at 2 to 50 mbps
two types of coaxial cables are
currently used in lan
50 ohm cable used for digital signaling
75 ohm cable used for analog signaling
and high speed digital signaling
coax requires fixed spacing between
connections
coax is more expensive yet it is more
resistant to electromagnetic
interference emi than twisted pair
cabling
it can transmit at a greater bandwidth
and distance
coax can come in two types of lands
thin net
rg58 size
thick net rg8 or rg11 size
there are two common types of coaxial
cable transmission methods
baseband
the cable carries only a single channel
baseband is a transmission method that
is accomplished by applying a direct
current to a cable
the current or signals hold binary
information
higher voltage usually represents the
binary value 1 whereas lower voltage
represents the binary value 0.
baseband permits only one signal to be
transmitted at a time example
ethernet broadband
the cable carries several usable
channels such as data voice audio and
video
broadband includes leased lines t1 and
t3
isdn
atm dsl
broadband wireless and ca tv
it carries several signals over a
different cable carries signals as light
waves allowing higher transmission
speeds and greater distances due to less
dilution it is also called optical fiber
fiber optic cable is the most reliable
cable type and it is also the expensive
one to install and terminate
the light source transmits the optical
signal on the fiber cable there are two
types of light sources
light emitting diodes leds and diode
lasers
light emitting diodes leds are the
sophisticated leds found in consumer
electronic less expensive than diode
lasers
they offer less bandwidth over a shorter
distance
diode lasers are an expensive
alternative
they require more expensive fiber cables
and light detectors
and the carriers on their backbone use
this optical source
there are two types of optical fiber
such as multimode fiber and single mode
fiber
multimode fiber where the light is
transmitted in different modes or paths
and fibers that are about 50 to 100
microns in diameter
single mode fiber is about 10 microns in
diameter
the transmitted light takes a direct
path down the center of the fiber
fiber optic cable has three basic
physical elements such as core
cladding and jacket
core is the innermost transmission
medium which can be glass or plastic
cladding is the next outer layer also
made of glass or plastic but having
different properties
it helps reflect the light back to the
core
jacket is the outermost layer providing
protection from heat
moisture and other environments now
discuss the different types of network
topologies
a network topology defines the manner in
which the network devices are organized
to facilitate communications a lan
topology defines this transmission
manner for a local area network
there are five common land topologies
such as bus ring
star
hierarchical and mesh
in a bus topology all transmissions of
the network nodes travel the full length
of the cable and are received by all
other stations
ethernet primarily uses this topology
however when any station on the bus
experiences cabling termination errors
the entire bus can cease to function
in a ring topology the network nodes are
connected by unidirectional transmission
links to form a closed loop
token ring and fddi use this topology
in a star topology the nodes of a
network are connected directly to a
central land device
the logical bus and ring topologies are
often implemented physically in a star
topology
although ethernet is logically thought
of as a bus topology its first
implementations were thin net and thick
net on a bus
tin based tea is actually wired as a
star topology
it provides more resiliencies for the
entire topology when a station
experiences errors
hierarchical or tree topology is a bus
type topology where branches with
multiple nodes are
possible in a mess topology all the
nodes are connected to every other node
in a network
this topology may be used to create
backbone redundant networks
a full mesh topology has every node
connected to every other node
a partial mesh topology may be used to
connect multiple full mesh networks
together
let us discuss network transmission
channel in the following what type of
media access technology is being used
the main resource that has to be shared
by all systems and devices on the
network is a network transmission
channel the media access technologies
are ethernet over stp utp in the
corporate network
token ring over coaxial cabling for lan
fddi over fiber for backbone
connectivity
or wi-fi over a frequency spectrum
there must be methods in place to make
sure that each system gets access to the
channel that the system's data is not
corrupted during transmission and that
there is a way to control traffic in
peak times
examples of media sharing technologies
include csma cd
csma ca
token passing under the ethernet carrier
sense multiple access
or csma with collision detection or cd
media access process
any computer on a csma with cd lan can
access the network anytime
before sending the data the csma with cd
hosts listen to the traffic on the
network
a host that wants to send the data waits
until there is no traffic
ethernet enables any host on the network
to transmit whenever the network is
quiet in addition the transmitting host
constantly monitors the wire to ensure
no other hosts begin transmitting
if the host detects another signal on
the wire it sends an extended jam signal
which causes all the nodes on the
segment to stop sending data
these nodes respond to the jam's signal
by waiting before attempting to transmit
again
csma with cd was created to overcome the
problem of collisions that occur when
packets are simultaneously transmitted
from different nodes
collisions occur when two hosts listen
for traffic and upon hearing none they
both transmit simultaneously
in this situation both transmissions are
damaged and the hosts must retransmit at
a later time
let us discuss the carrier sense
multiple access with collision avoidance
in the next screen carrier sense
or csma
workstations are attached to two coaxial
cables
each coax cable carries data signals in
one direction
a workstation monitors its receive cable
to determine whether the carrier is busy
then it communicates on its transmit
cable if no carrier is detected
it sends a short message ready to send
or rts to avoid any collision
rts communicates to everyone to retreat
for that duration
it also contains destination address and
duration of message
once the medium is free destination
sends a message clear to send or cts
thus the workstation transmits its
intention to send when it feels the line
is clear due to a precedence that is
based on previously established tables
csma does not have a feature to avoid
the problem of one workstation
dominating a conversation
in the following screen we will discuss
the three types of land transmission
methods now discuss the flavors of land
transmission methods
there are three flavors of land
transmission methods they are unicast
the packet is sent from a single source
to a single destination address
multicast the source packet is copied
and sent to specific multiple
destinations on the network
broadcast
the packet is copied and sent to all the
nodes on the network or segment of a
network
let us identify various network devices
and the files and hubs operate at the
physical layer of the osi model
repeaters amplify the data signal to
extend the length of a network segment
hubs and repeaters are used to connect
multiple lan devices such as servers and
workstations
bridges also amplify data signals
if the destination computer is on the
local network segment it does not for
the data
bridges operate at the data link layer
and osi layer too
they do not use ip addresses ip
information is attached in the network
layer layer 3.
bridge automatically forwards any
broadcast traffic to all ports
an error state known as a broadcast
storm can develop
overwhelming the network devices
a switch is similar to a bridge or a hub
switches send the data packet only to
the specified port where the destination
mac address is located
a switch relies on the mac address to
determine the source and destination of
a packet which is layer 2 networking
switches primarily operate at the data
link layer layer 2 although intelligent
layer 3 switching techniques combining
switching and routing are more
frequently used
although most standard switches operate
at the data link layer layer 3 switches
operate at the network layer and
function like a router by incorporating
some router features
routers add more intelligence to the
process of forwarding packets
when a router receives a packet it looks
at the network layer source and
destination addresses i p address to
determine the path the packet should
take and forward the packet only to the
intended network
this prevents unnecessary network
traffic from being sent over the network
by blocking broadcast information and
traffic to unknown addresses
routers operate at the network layer
layer 3 of the osi protocol model
routers are necessary when communicating
between virtual lans vlans
a wireless access point wap is a device
that allows wireless devices to connect
to a wired network using wi-fi bluetooth
or related standards
the wap usually connects to a router via
a wired network and can relay data
between the wireless devices such as
computers or printers and wired devices
on the network
a hotspot is a common public application
of waps where wireless clients can
connect to the internet without regard
for the particular networks to which
they have attached for the moment
a collection of connected hot spots can
be referred to as a lily pad netland is
a collection of nodes that are grouped
together in a single broadcast domain
and a switch and are based on something
other than physical segment location
virtual local area networks vlans allow
the ports on the same or different
switches to be grouped so that the
traffic is confined to the members of
that group only
it also restricts broadcast unicast and
multicast traffic
a vlan creates an isolated broadcast
domain and a switch with multiple
broadcast domains similar to a router
a vlan also restricts flooding to only
those ports included in the vlan however
vlans cannot route from one to another
such routing would defeat the purpose of
the vlan to isolate the traffic from the
general traffic flow
vlans can aid in isolating segments with
sensitive data from the rest of the
broadcast domain and can increase
security assurance
they can reduce the number of router
hops and increase the usable bandwidth
reduce routing broadcast because acls
control the stations and the traffic
they receive
vlans are segmented logically rather
than physically
they may be created to segregate job or
department functions that require heavy
bandwidth without affecting the rest of
the network
vlans can span across multiple switches
and you can have more than one vlan on
each switch
for multiple vlans on multiple switches
to be able to communicate via a single
link between the switches
you must use a process called trunking
trunking is a technology that allows
information from multiple vlans to be
carried over just one link between
switches
the vlan trunking protocol vtp is a
protocol that switches use to
communicate amongst themselves about
vlan configuration
when a vlan is implemented with private
port or single user switching it
provides fairly stringent security
because broadcast vulnerabilities are
minimized
a closed vlan authenticates a user to an
access control list on a central
authentication server where the user is
assigned authorization parameters to
determine his or her level of networks
are the software products that can be
run on computers or other network
devices
they can be multi-protocol and can
examine the entire packet
mail gateways are used to link
dissimilar mail programs
gateways can also be used to translate
between two dissimilar network protocols
microsoft windows describe the standard
networking feature as internet
connection sharing which acts as a
gateway offering a connection between
the internet and an internal network
such a system might also act as a
dynamic host configuration protocol or
dhcp server
dhcp is a protocol used by networked
devices or clients to obtain various
parameters necessary for the clients to
operate in an internet protocol ip
network
by using this protocol system
administration workload decreases and
devices can be added to the network with
minimal or no manual configurations
in the next screen
we will focus on network access control
devices network access control devices
are used to allow only the legitimate
traffic on the network
an example is a firewall
firewalls were invented in the 1980s
these devices are placed at a network
boundary designed to block unwanted
incoming or outgoing traffic
a firewall works by examining each
packet and consulting a list of rules to
determine whether the packet should be
permitted to pass through the firewall
or be blocked
in a large organization the list of
rules in a firewall can become heavy
possibly resulting in unwanted traffic
entering or leaving the network
in the next screen we will look at the
types of files act as perimeter access
control devices
firewalls are categorized into packet
filtering application level circuit
level and stateful inspection
packet filtering firewall
the packet filtering firewall examines
the source and destination address of
the incoming data packet
this firewall either blocks the packet
or passes it to its intended destination
network
the firewall can allow or deny the
access to the specific applications or
services based on the access control
lists acls
the firewall can be configured to allow
access to authorized application port or
service numbers only
it looks at the data packet to get
information about the source and
destination addresses of an incoming
packet the sessions communication
protocol such as tcp udp or icmp
and the source and destination
application port for the desired service
a packet level firewall does not keep a
history of the communication sessions
it operates at the network layer of the
osi model and offers good performance
a dynamic packet filtering firewall
employs a technology that enables the
modification of the firewall security
rule
this type of technology is used mostly
for providing limited support for udp
application level firewall
an application level firewall is
commonly a host computer that is running
proxy server software making it a proxy
server
this firewall works by transferring a
copy of each accepted data packet from
one network to another thereby masking
the data's origin
a proxy server can control which
services a workstation uses on the
internet
it also aids in protecting the network
from outsiders who may be trying to get
information about the network's design
it inspects the packet up through the
application layer and can make access
decisions based on the content of the
packets
also called an application layer gateway
the application level firewall is
commonly used with a dual home to host
it operates at the osi protocol layer 7
the application layer
it is more secure because it examines
the packet at the application layer but
it does so at the expense of performance
it controls the services a workstation
uses on the internet and it aids in
protecting the network from outsiders
who may be trying to get information
about the networks designed
as opposed to packet firewalls proxy
firewalls capture some session history
proxy firewalls have higher protocols
carried on low level protocols such as
email or html
circuit level firewall
similar to an application of a firewall
a circuit level firewall is used as a
proxy server
although it is similar to the
application level firewall this firewall
does not need a special proxy
application software
circuit level firewall creates a virtual
circuit between the workstation client
or destination and the server or host
it works at the session layer of the osi
model and does not carry out deep packet
inspection
it also provides security for a wide
variety of protocols and is easy to
maintain and takes decisions based upon
protocol header and session information
for example
socket secure socks creates a circuit
between client and server without
requiring knowledge about the internet
working service as is no application
specific controls
a stateful inspection firewall
intercepts incoming packets at the
network layer and then uses an
inspection engine to extract state
related information from upper layers
this firewall maintains the information
in a dynamic state table and evaluates
subsequent connection attempts
stateful inspection firewalls keep low
protocol records at the ip level
the packets are queued and analyzed at
all osi layers against the state table
by examining the state and context of
the incoming data packets protocols that
are considered connectionless such as
udp-based applications and remote
procedure calls rpcs can be tracked
easily
let us understand the firewall
architectures in the following screen
four basic types of firewall
architectures are packet filtering
routers
screened host firewalls
dual home post firewalls and screened
subnet firewalls
some of these architectures are
specifically associated with one of the
previously discussed firewall types
while other architectures can employ a
combination of types
packet filtering routers
packet filtering router is the common
and oldest firewall device in use
a packet filtering router is located
between the private trusted network and
the untrusted network or network segment
this firewall architecture is used as a
packet filtering firewall
a packet filtering router is sometimes
used to directly manage access to a
demilitarized zone dmz network segment
a dmz is a network added between an
internal network and an external network
to provide an additional layer of
security
it is also called a perimeter network
screened host firewalls
a screened host firewall uses two
network cards to connect to the trusted
and untrusted networks
however it adds a screening router
between the host and the untrusted
network
it provides network layer or routing and
application layer or proxy services
this type of firewall system requires an
intruder to penetrate two separate
systems before he or she can compromise
the trusted network
the host is configured between the local
trusted network and untrusted network
since the firewall can be the focus of
external attacks it is sometimes called
the sacrificial lamb
dual homed host firewalls
a dual home to host has two network
interface cards nics but no screening
router
it uses two nic's to attach to two
separate networks commonly a trusted
network and an untrusted network
this architecture is a simple
configuration that consists of a single
computer the host with two nics one
connected to the local trusted network
and the other connected to the internet
or an untrusted external network
a dual home host firewall usually acts
to block or filter some or all of the
traffic trying to pass between the
networks
screened subnet firewalls
a screened subnet firewall also uses two
nics
it has two screening routers with the
host acting as a proxy server on its own
network segment
one screening router controls local
traffic to the network while the second
monitors and controls incoming and
outgoing internet traffic
it employs two packet filtering routers
and a bastion host now take a look at
some important network security terms
such as demilitarized zone dmz bastion
host and endpoint security
demilitarized zone dmz
dmz also known as perimeter networking
is a physical or logical sub network
that contains and exposes an
organization's external services to a
larger untrusted network usually the
internet
it is the buffer zone between an
unprotected network and a protected
network that allows for the monitoring
and regulation of traffic between the
two
the purpose of a dmz is to add a layer
of security to an organization's local
area network lan
the name is derived from the term
demilitarized zone an area between
nation states in which military action
is not permitted
bastion host
a bastion host is any computer that is
fully exposed to attack by being on the
public side of the demilitarized zone
dmz unprotected by a firewall or
filtering router
firewalls and routers anything that
provides perimeter access control
security can be considered bastion hosts
other types of bastion hosts can include
web mail dns and ftp servers
endpoint security it is an information
security concept which assumes that each
device or endpoint is responsible for
its own security
traditionally firewalls central virus
scanners and other intrusion detection
or intrusion prevention devices are
responsible for securing an endpoint
endpoint security places the
responsibility of security on the device
some of the examples are broadband users
increasing use of desktop firewalls spam
and antivirus software it also includes
the protection of a businesses network
from employee memory devices that may
unknowingly contain malware firewall
administrator at nutri worldwide inc has
been working on a new firewall the
firewall is able to do a deep packet
inspection on all the layers mentioned
in the osi model
the firewall is transparent to the user
and is context based
it can also discard unsolicited packets
arriving in the network from the
internet
which type of firewall is kevin working
on
it is a stateful inspection about
networks in this screen
a data network consists of two or more
computers connected for the purpose of
sharing files printers data and so forth
to communicate on the network every
workstation must have an nic inserted
into the computer and transmission
medium such as copper fiber or wireless
a network operating system or nos
and a lan device such as a hub bridge
router or switch to physically connect
the computers together
in addition to these local area networks
there are two other common types of
lands
campus area network or can and
metropolitan area network or man campus
area network is a typically large campus
network that connects multiple buildings
with each other across a high
performance switched backbone on the
main campus metropolitan area network or
mann is essentially a land that extends
over a city or metropolitan area
it is commonly a backbone network that
connects business to winds often using
sonnet or fddi rings provided by the
telecommunications vendors
man is however not often used as a
description let us look at the types of
networks in this screen
internet is a global network of public
networks and internet service providers
or isps throughout the world
internet can be utilized either by the
public or private network with a vpn
an intranet is an internet-like logical
network that uses a firm's internal
physical network infrastructure
internet provides more security and
control than the public posting on the
internet
extranet is a private network that uses
internet protocols
in contrast to an internet certain users
outside the company such as partners
vendors etc can access an extranet
however the general public will not have
the access
a wide area network or wan is a network
of subnetworks that are physically or
logically interconnected
over a larger geographic area than the
lands
a wan may be privately operated for a
specific user community may support
multiple communication protocols or may
provide network connectivity and
services via interconnected network
segments such as extranets intranets and
vpns
when technologies will be explained in
the following area network or when is a
network of sub-networks that are
physically or logically interconnected
over a larger geographic area than lands
local area networks lands and metro area
networks mans are combined to form
a wan may be privately operated for a
specific user community may support
multiple communication protocols or may
provide network connectivity and
services via interconnected network
segments such as extranets intranets and
vpns to become familiar with the various
type of wan technologies you must
understand when protocols topologies and
devices
similar to land protocols land protocols
are the rules for communicating between
computers on a wan
since wan is often used for connecting
diverse networks these protocols address
the issues involved with communications
between many large and unrelated
networks
wands use packet switching and circuit
switching technologies
the different types of wand technologies
are when switching and devices
network address translation nat
frame relay
multi-protocol label switching mpls and
voice over internet protocol boip
when switching is required when the
network grows and needs more than a
single point-to-point connection
there are two main flavors of wan
switching
circuit switching and packet switching
circuit switch networks
circuit switching is defined as a
switching system in which a dedicated
physical circuit path must exist between
the sender and receiver for the duration
of the transmission or the call a
circuit switch network describes a type
of wind that consists of a physical
permanent connection from one point to
another
this technology is older than packet
switching telephone is an example of
circuit switch networks
packet switch networks
packet switching is defined as a
networking method where nodes share
bandwidth with each other by sending
small data units called packets
a packet switch network psn or psdn is a
network that uses packet switching
technology for data transfer
in contrast to circuit switch networks
the data in packet switch networks is
broken into packets and then sent to the
next destination based on the router's
understanding of the best available
route
examples of packet switch networks
include frame relay and voip
common when devices
when devices enable the use of lan
protocols in topologies
the following are examples of these
device types
routers
routers are extremely important in the
wan environment especially for ip
internet traffic
multiplexers
commonly referred to as a mux a
multiplexer is a device that enables
more than one signal to be sent out
simultaneously over one physical circuit
when switches
wan switches are multi-port networking
devices that are used in carrier
networks
they operate at the data link layer and
typically switch frame relay
and x.25
these switches connect private data over
public data circuits by using digital
address translation or nat describes the
process of converting an ip address
valid within one network to a different
ip address valid within another network
in other words nat converts a private ip
address on the inside trusted network to
a registered real ip address seen by the
untrusted outside network
the internet assigned number authority
iana has reserved three blocks of the ip
address space for private internet
addresses
10.0.0.0 through 10.255.255.255.
172.16.0.0
through 172.31.255.255.
192.168.0.0
through 192.168.255.255.
relay is a high performance lan protocol
that operates at the data link layer of
the osi model
originally designed for use across isdn
interfaces it is currently used with a
variety of other interfaces and is a
major standard for high-speed wind
communications
frame relay is a successor to x.25 and
lapb
it is the fastest of the wan protocols
listed because of its simplified framing
approach which utilizes no error
correction frame relay uses svcs pvcs
and data link connection identifiers
dlcis for addressing
since it requires access to a high
quality digital network infrastructure
it is not available mechanism that
directs data from one network node to
the next based on short path labels
the labels identify virtual links or
paths between distant nodes rather than
endpoints
mpls can encapsulate packets of various
network protocols it can be used to
carry different kinds of traffic
including both voice telephone traffic
and ip packets
mpls operates at a layer 2.5
voice over internet protocol is a
category of hardware and software
it enables people to use the internet as
the transmission medium for telephone
calls by sending voice data in packets
using ip rather than by traditional
circuit transmissions of the pstn
voip is one of the several digital
multi-service access ip technologies
that combine many types of data such as
voice audio and video into a single ip
packet which provides major benefits in
the areas of cost interoperability and
channel over ethernet or fcoe is a
computer network technology that enables
fiber channel communications to run
directly over ethernet
it allows fibre channel to use 10
gigabit ethernet networks or higher
speeds while preserving the fiber
channel protocol
fcoe converges storage and ip protocols
on a single cable transport and
interface by moving fibre channel
traffic across existing high-speed
ethernet infrastructure
internet small computer system interface
or iscsi is a transport layer protocol
that defines how small computer system
interface or scuzzy packets should be
transported over a tcp slash i p network
iscsi enables data transfers over
internet and manages storage over long
distances
it can be used to transmit data over
local area networks or lands
wide area networks or winds or the
internet
it can also enable location independent
data storage and retrieval
let us discuss virtualized networks in
the following slides virtual storage
area network or vsan is a collection of
ports from a set of connected fibre
channel switches that forms a virtual
fabric
ports within a single switch can be
partitioned into multiple vsans despite
sharing hardware resources
vsan allows isolation of traffic within
particular portions of a storage area
network or sand by creating a logical
partition
software-defined networking or sdn
allows network administrators to support
a network fabric across multi-vendor
equipment by decoupling the control from
the physical infrastructure
some of the limitations of sdn are
complexity inability to scale and vendor
dependence
guest operating systems in a virtual
machine is the operating system or os
that is installed in addition to the
host or main os
security practitioners must ensure that
the host system is hardened
in the next screen we will focus on
remote access now learn about remote
access
remote access technologies can be
defined as the data networking
technologies that are uniquely focused
on providing the remote user such as
telecommuter internet or internet user
or extranet user or partner the access
into a network while striving to
maintain the principal tenants of
confidentiality availability and
integrity
there are many advantages of employing
secure remote network access
remote access technologies reduce
networking costs by using the internet
to replace expensive dedicated network
lines
they provide employees with flexible
work styles such as telecommuting
they build efficient ties with customers
suppliers and employees
let us look at remote access protocols
in the following remote access protocols
include
vpn using pptp and l2tp
internet protocol security ipsec
secure socket layer
ssl
secure http shttp and secure shell ssh
vpn is created by building a secure
communication link between two nodes
emulating the properties of a
point-to-point private link
a vpn can be used to facilitate remote
access vpn network to network vpn and
internet access vpn
vpn and remote access protocols are
point-to-point tunneling protocol pptp
and layer 2 tunneling protocol l2tp
pptp works at the data link layer of the
osi model
it is designed for individual client to
server connections hence it allows only
a single point-to-point connection per
session
pptp allows ip ipx or net beui traffic
to be encrypted and then encapsulated in
an ip header
this ip header will be sent across a
corporate ip internet work or a public
ip internet work such as the internet
l2tp is a combination of pptp and layer
2 forwarding protocol l2f and also works
at the data link layer
similar to pptp l2tp was designed for a
single point-to-point client-to-server
connections
l2tp allows ip ipx or net be uui traffic
to be encrypted and then sent over any
medium that supports point-to-point
datagram delivery such as ip
x.25 frame relay atm
internet protocol security or ipsec in
this screen
internet protocol security ipsec is a
protocol suite for securing internet
protocol ip communications by
authenticating and encrypting each ip
packet of a communication session
ipsec also includes protocols for
establishing mutual authentication
between agent at the beginning of the
session and negotiation of cryptographic
keys to be used during the session
ipsec internet protocol security suite
of protocols adds a cryptographic layer
to both ipv4 and
ipv6 it is one of the methods for
providing virtual private networks vpn
which allow you to send private data
over an insecure network such as the
internet the data crosses a public
network but is virtually private
the two basic security protocols
authentication header ah an
authentication protocol and
encapsulating security payload esp
an authentication and encryption
protocol
in the next screen we will look at the
modes of operation on modes of ipsec
operation are as follows
in tunnel mode ipsec is used to protect
a complete encapsulated ip datagram
after the ip header has already been
applied to it
the ipsec headers appear in front of the
original ip header and then a new ip
header is added in front of the ipsec
header
that is to say the entire original ip
datagram is secured and then
encapsulated within another ip datagram
tunnel mode used by security gateways
which can provide point-to-point ipsec
tunnels it encrypts the entire packet
the payload and header are protected
that is encryption and hash
used for network to network hosted
network and host to host communications
as its name suggests in transport mode
the protocol protects the message passed
down to ip from the transport layer the
message is processed by ah esp and the
appropriate headers added in front of
the transport udp or tcp header
the ip header is then added in front of
that by ip
another way of looking at this is as
follows
normally the transport layer packages
data for transmission and sends it to ip
from ip's perspective this transport
layer message is the payload of the ip
datagram when ipsec is used in transport
mode the ipsec header is applied only
over this ip playload not the ip header
so in this mode only the payload is
protected that is encryption and hash
ip headers are not encrypted if ah is
used then ip address cannot be
translated that is nat
it is used for host to host
communications only
in the next screen we will understand
ipsec security protocol header ah
provides authentication and integrity
for each packet of network data it
offers no confidentiality but rather
acts as a digital signature for the data
ah also protects against replay attacks
where data is sniffed off a network and
resent
often in an attempt to fraudulently
reuse encrypted authentication
credentials
ah operates directly on top of ip using
ip protocol number 51.
in ah transport mode the ip packet is
modified only slightly to include the
new ah header between the ip header and
the protocol payload tcp udp etc and
there is a shuffling of the protocol
code that links the various headers
together
this protocol shuffling is required to
allow the original ip packet to be
reconstituted at the other end
after the ipsec headers have been
validated upon receipt they're stripped
off and the original protocol type tcp
udp etc is stored back in the ip header
it provides data authentication only no
encryption
it is implemented on the communicating
endpoints useful when encryption is not
needed or is not permitted
tunnel mode creates a new ip header and
uses it as the outermost ip header of
the datagram
the ah header follows the new ip header
the original datagram both the ip header
and the original payload comes last
ah authenticates the entire datagram
which means that the responding system
can detect whether the datagram changed
while in transit
when either ends of a security
association as a gateway use tunnel mode
in tunnel mode the source and
destination addresses in the outermost
ip header do not need to be the same as
those in the original ip header for
example two security gateways may
operate an ah tunnel to authenticate all
traffic between the networks they
connect together in fact this is a very
typical configuration
the main advantage to using tunnel mode
is that telemode totally protects the
encapsulated ip datagram in addition
tunnel mode makes it possible to use
private addresses
transport mode encapsulates just the
datagrams payload and is designed
strictly for host to host communications
the original ip header is left in place
except for the shuffled protocol field
and it means that among other things the
source and destination ip addresses are
unchanged
it provides confidentiality for the
segment's payload data authentication
for the packet's headers and payload or
both
it is implemented on the communicating
input floating security payload esp is a
member of the ipsec protocol suite
in ipsec it provides origin authenticity
integrity and confidentiality protection
of packets
esp also supports encryption only and
authentication only configurations but
using encryption without authentication
is strongly discouraged because it is
insecure
unlike authentication header ah esp in
transport mode does not provide
integrity and authentication for the
entire ip packet
however in tunnel mode where the entire
original ip packet is encapsulated with
the new packet header added esp
protection is afforded to the whole
inner ip packet including the inner
header while the outer header including
any outer ipv4 options or ipv6 extension
headers remain unprotected
esp operates directly on top of ip using
ip protocol number 50.
esp in tunnel mode encapsulates an
entire ip datagram inside the encrypted
shell it provides confidentiality
authentication or both for entire
original packet
it must be implemented on ipsec gateways
acting as such
an additional ip header identifying the
gateways is prepended
the next slide deals with the components
of the ipsec process security
architecture uses the concept of a
security association as the basis for
building security functions into ip
a security association is simply the
bundle of algorithms and parameters such
as keys that is being used to encrypt
and authenticate a particular flow in
one direction
therefore in normal bi-directional
traffic the flows are secured by a pair
of security associations
authentication header or ah and
encapsulating security payload or esp
may be used separately or in combination
an ipsec security association or sa is a
simplex one-way connection that may be
used to negotiate esp or ah parameters
if two systems communicate via esp
they use two sas one for each direction
if the systems leverage ah in addition
to esp
they use two more sas for a total of
four
each simplex sa connection is identified
by a unique 32-bit number known as the
security parameter index or spi
the sa process is managed by internet
security association and key management
protocol or isa kmp
it provides a key exchange framework
negotiates establishment modification
and deletion of essays
it also negotiates key exchange protocol
to be used
the internet key exchange or ike
protocol is a key management protocol
standard that is used in conjunction
with the ipsec standard
ike enhances ipsec by providing
additional features flexibility and ease
of configuration for the ipsec standard
ipsec can however be configured without
ike
a variety of encryption algorithms like
aes
des
md percent
sha-1 can be employed by ipsec
key exchange ike negotiates the
algorithm selection process
benefits provided by ike include the
following
eliminates the need to manually specify
all the ipsec security parameters in the
crypto maps that both peers
allow specifying a lifetime for the
ipsec security association
allows encryption keys to change during
ipsec sessions
allows ipsec to provide anti-replay
services
permits certification authority ca
support for a manageable scalable ipsec
implementation
allows dynamic authentication of peers
let us look at a flowchart of ipsec
process in the next involves many
component technologies and encryption
methods yet ipsec's operation can be
broken down into five main steps
interesting traffic initiates the ipsec
process
traffic is deemed interesting when the
ipsec security policy configured in the
ipsec peers starts the ike process
ike phase 1
ike authenticates ipsec peers and
negotiates ike sas during this phase
setting up a secure channel for
negotiating ipsec essays in phase two
ike phase two
ike negotiates ipsec sa parameters and
sets up matching ipsec essays in the
peers
data is transferred between ipsec peers
based on the ipsec parameters and keys
stored in the sa database
ipsec tunnel termination
ipsec essays terminate through deletion
or by timing some common security
protocols in this screen
pretty good privacy pgp was designed by
phil zimmerman as a freeware email
security program and was released in
1991.
it was the first widespread public key
encryption program pgp is a complete
crypto system that uses cryptographic
protection to protect email and files
it can use rsa public key encryption for
key management and use idea symmetric
cipher for bulk encryption of data
although the user has the option of
picking different types of algorithms
for these functions
pgp can provide confidentiality by using
the idea encryption algorithm integrity
by using the md5 hashing algorithm
authentication by using the public key
certificates
and non-repudiation by using
cryptographically signed messages
pgp uses its own type of digital
certificates rather than what is used in
pki but they both have similar purposes
the user's private key is generated and
encrypted when the application asks the
user to randomly type on her keyboard
for a specific amount of time
instead of using passwords pgp uses past
phrases
the passphrase is used to encrypt the
user's private key that is stored on her
hard drive
pgp does not use a hierarchy of cas or
any type of formal trust certificates
but instead relies on a web of trust in
its key management approach
each user generates and distributes his
or her public key and users sign each
other's public keys which creates a
community of users who trust each other
this is different from the ca approach
where no one trusts each other
the only trust is the ca
the signer must be regarded as a trusted
introducer collection of signed keys is
referred to as a key ring though their
names are very similar there is a
difference between secure http s http
and http secure
https
shttp is a technology that protects each
message sent between two computers while
https protects the communication channel
between two computers messages and all
https uses ssl tls and http to provide a
protected circuit between a client and
server
so shttp is used if an individual
message needs to be encrypted but if all
information that passes between two
computers must be encrypted then https
is used which is ssl over http
unlike http it is a stateful protocol
the initial connection remains up
between exchanges
an shttp session is identified by urls
with
colon backslash backslash http secure
https is http running over ssl
http works at the application layer and
ssl works at the transport layer
secure sockets layer ssl uses public key
encryption and provides data encryption
server authentication message integrity
and optional client authentication
when a client accesses a website that
website may have both secured and public
portions
the secured portion will require the
user to be authenticated in some fashion
when the client goes from a public page
on the website to a secured page the web
server will start the necessary tasks to
invoke ssl and protect this type of
communication
https uses standard port 443
it encrypts all information that passes
over the connection at the session layer
unlike shttp
ssl can be applied to non-http traffic
an https session is identified by urls
with https colon backslash backslash
the ssl protocol was developed by
netscape in 1994 to secure internet
client server transactions
mostly used for e-commerce applications
the ssl protocol authenticates the
server to the client using public key
cryptography and digital certificates in
addition this protocol provides for
optional client-to-server authentication
it supports the use of rsa public key
algorithms idea des and three des
private key algorithms and the md5 hash
function
the general steps are as follows
the client that is the browser requests
a server
the server sends its digital certificate
to the client
the ca verifies the server's public key
and the client generates a symmetric key
session
the session key is encrypted with the
server's public key and sent to the
server
server and browser can now send
encrypted messages
an ssl session is identified by urls
starting with https colon backslash
backup electronic transaction sct is a
security technology proposed by visa and
mastercard to allow for more secure
credit card transaction possibilities
than what is currently available
sct has been waiting in the wings for
full implementation and acceptance as a
standard for quite some time
although set provides an effective way
of transmitting credit card information
businesses and users do not see it as
efficient because it requires more
parties to coordinate their efforts more
software installation and configuration
for each entity involved and more effort
and cost than the widely used ssl method
sct is a cryptographic protocol and
infrastructure developed to send
encrypted credit card numbers over the
internet
the following entities would be involved
with an sct transaction which would
require each of them to upgrade their
software and possibly their hardware
electronic wallet digital certificate
holding user financial information
software running on the merchant's web
server and payment server at the
merchant discuss the various types of
remote access security methods
restricted address
this method filters out unauthorized
users based on their source protocol
address ip or other lan protocol
caller id
it checks the incoming phone number of
the caller against an approved phone
list before accepting the session
callback
a user attempting to initiate the
session supplies a password or some type
of identifying code
the access server then hangs up and
calls the user back at a predetermined
discuss various types of multimedia
collaborations
remote or virtual meetings
these are real-time interactions that
take place over the internet using
integrated audio and video chat tools
and application sharing
instant messaging abbreviated as i am is
a type of communication service that
enables you to create a private chat
room with another individual to
communicate real time over the internet
telecollaboration
refers to a set of software technologies
that enable the integration and
extension of personal desktop
collaboration into high definition video
conferencing solutions
telepresence
a set of technologies which allows a
person to feel as if they were present
to give the appearance of being present
or to have an effect via tele-robotics
at a place other than their true
location
the next screen will focus on wireless
technology is the fastest growing area
of network connectivity
security is an extreme concern here
because all wireless technologies mobile
phones satellite transmissions and so
forth are inherently susceptible to
interception
encryption standards are rapidly being
developed to combat this problem
there are various wireless technologies
such as ieee wireless standards
spread spectrum technologies direct
sequence spread spectrum and frequency
hopping spread spectrum eee 802.11
refers to a family of specifications for
w lands developed by a working group of
the ieee
802.11 also generically refer to the
ieee committee responsible for setting
the various wireless lan standards
the 802.11 specification identifies an
over-the-air interface between a mobile
device wireless client and a base
station or between two mobile device
wireless clients
the original ieee wireless lan standard
that provides one or two mbps
transmission speed in the 2.4 gigahertz
band using either fhss or dss which is
covered later in the spread spectrum
technologies
the modulation used in 802.11 is
commonly phase shift keying
psk
spread spectrum uses a radio
transmission mode that broadcast signals
over a range of frequencies
the receiving mobile device must know
the correct frequency of the spread
spectrum signal being broadcast two
different spread spectrum technologies
for 2.4 gigahertz wireless lands
currently exist
direct sequence spread spectrum dss and
frequency hopping spread spectrum fhss
is a wideband spread spectrum
transmission technology that generates a
redundant bit pattern for each bit to be
transmitted
dss spreads the signal over a wide
frequency band in which the source
transmitter maps each bit of data into a
pattern of chips
the dss transmitter and receiver must be
synchronized to operate properly
dss spreads across the spectrum but the
number of independent non-overlapping
channels in the 2.4 gigahertz band is
small typically only three
some dss products enable users to deploy
more than one channel in the same area
by separating the 2.4 gigahertz band
into multiple sub bands each of which
contains an independent dss network
fhss uses a narrow band carrier that
continually changes frequency in a known
pattern
the fhss algorithm spreads the signal by
operating on one frequency for a short
duration and then hopping to another
frequency
the minimum number of frequencies
engaged in the hopping pattern and the
maximum frequency dwell time how long it
stays on each frequency before it
changes are restricted by the fcc which
requires that 75 or more frequencies be
used with the maximum dwell time of 400
milliseconds eee 802.11 wireless
networks operate in one of two
operational modes ad hoc mode and
infrastructure mode
ad hoc mode
in ad hoc mode each mobile device client
communicates directly with the other
mobile device clients within the network
ad hoc mode is designed so that only the
clients within transmission range within
the same cell of each other can
communicate
infrastructure mode
each mobile device client in
infrastructure mode sends all of its
communications to a network device
called an access point ap
the access point acts as a bridge does
in lan and forwards the communications
to the appropriate network either the
wlan or another wireless network
the wireless standard of 802.11 family
are 802.11a specified speeds up to 54
mbps and the 5 gigahertz band
802.11b
specified speed of up to 11 mbps and the
2.4 gigahertz band
802.11g specified speeds of up to 54
mbps in the 2.4 gigahertz band
802.11 in
specified speeds of up to 130 mbps in
the 2.4 gigahertz or 5 gigahertz band
and 802.11i
specified speeds of security protocol
in the next screen we will learn about
is a wireless personal area network pan
technology for relatively low-speed data
communication over short distances
it is a peer-to-peer protocol created to
connect multiple consumer mobile
information devices transparently such
as cellular phones laptops handheld
computers digital cameras printers etc
bluetooth uses the ieee
802.15 specification and the 2.4 to 2.5
gigahertz band with fhss technology
bluetooth enables mobile devices to
avoid interference from other signals by
hopping to a new frequency after
transmitting or receiving a packet
typical bluetooth applications include
wireless mobile phone headsets
computer mics and keyboards
wireless stereo headphones and gps
receivers
since bluetooth uses radio spectrum
devices do not require line of sight to
connect
bluetooth data rates range from one
megabit per second to three megabits per
second
bluetooth power consumption is very low
which makes it suitable for low power
devices
the maximum range for communications is
10 meters
bluetooth devices can authenticate
through a process called pairing during
which two devices can exchange a
cryptographic secret key that the two
devices can later use to securely
identify themselves
communications between paired devices
can also be encrypted
bluetooth operates in two modes
discovery mode and automatic types of
attacks that can be carried out on a
bluetooth enabled device are explained
in this screen
they are blue jacking
blue snarfing
blue bugging
backdoor attacks and denial of service
attacks when you pair the bluetooth
devices a message will normally appear
on your handset
the message can be up to 248 characters
in length and is often abused by others
as a method of sending messages to your
device
your device will display the message and
then ask you for permission to pair your
device with the attacker
this can be a precursor to other attacks
especially if the message tells you that
you have won something and goes on to
say that you need to input a specific
four-digit code to collect your prize
if you were to type in this four digit
code the pairing passcode your device
would then be open for any of the other
attacks the term snarf refers to taking
a large document or file for the purpose
of using it with or without the author's
expressed permission
on many bluetooth devices it is possible
to complete the pairing process without
informing the user of the target
handheld
once the connection is established the
attacker can gain access to restricted
information
this information can be anything from
pictures files contracts device settings
calendar information as well as serial
and sim numbers that uniquely identify
your debugging this type of
vulnerability can allow an attacker to
create a serial connection to the target
device
the attacker could then initiate calls
sometimes to international or pay per
minute numbers forward calls send and
receive sms messages connect to the
internet and even monitor calls on a gsm
phone attacks of this nature can often
provide the attacker with the tools he
or she will need to steal your identity
and possibly cause damage to the user
financially
every bluetooth user knows about pairing
which is the action of linking two
bluetooth capable devices for the
purpose of transferring data
backdoor attacks this attack is carried
out through this specific pairing
mechanism by establishing a trust
relationship between the user's device
and the attacker's laptop or pda
dos attacks
these type of attacks serve only to be
annoyance to the target user's device
the attacker can use his or her
bluetooth device to send many pairing
requests to the user's bluetooth handset
it can however temporarily paralyze a
phone or pda and cause a notable drain
on the batteries now learn about various
wireless security systems
wireless is one of the newest
communication technology frontiers
offering the possibility of always on
instant mobile communications
uses airways for communication makes it
more vulnerable for attacks
with abundant use of wireless enabled
devices like laptops etc it is difficult
to secure manage and roll out
however the vulnerabilities inherent to
wireless computing present daunting
hurdles
some of the wireless vulnerabilities are
dos attacks
a denial of service dos attack is an
example of the failure of the tenant of
availability
wap gap
a specific security issue that is
associated with wap is the wap gap
a wap gap results from the requirement
to change security protocols at the
carrier's wap gateway from the wireless
wtls to ssl for use over the wired
network
insertion attacks
in an assertion attack unauthorized
devices are deployed to gain access to
an existing network
rogue access point
an assertion attack could be facilitated
by the deployment of rogue access points
either by a hacker or by well-meaning
internal employees seeking to enhance
wireless coverage
wep weakness
most wep products implement a 64-bit
shared key using 40 bits of this for the
secret key and 24 bits for the
initialization vector
the key is installed at the wired
network ap and must be entered into each
client as well
service set identifier ssid issue
the service set identifier ssid is an
identification value programmed in the
access point or group of access points
to identify the local wireless subnet
this segmentation of the wireless
network into multiple networks is a form
of authentication check
wireless scanning and eavesdropping
wireless technology is also vulnerable
to eavesdropping especially because
intruders do not have to physically tap
into a network
war driving
ward driving also war walking is a term
used to describe a hacker who armed with
a laptop and a wireless adapter card and
traveling via a car bus subway train or
other form of transport goes around
sniffing for w lands
common war driving exploits find many
wireless networks with wep disabled and
using only the ssid for access control
wireless packet snippers
wireless packet analyzers or snippers
work the same way as wired network
packet analyzers
they capture packets from the data
stream and allow the user to open them
up and look at or decode them
wireless encryption protocol
there are many different types of
wireless encryption protocols
wep
short for wired equivalency privacy a
security protocol for wireless local
area networks w lands defined in the
802.11b standard
lan
and are inherently more secure than wlan
because lands are somewhat protected by
the physicalities of their structure
having some or all part of the network
inside a building they can be protected
from unauthorized access
wlans which are over radio waves do not
have the same physical structure and
therefore are more vulnerable to
tampering
wired equivalency privacy wep uses
stream cipher rc4 for confidentiality
and crc32 checksum for data integrity
wpa psk is an authentication mechanism
in which users provide some form of
credentials to verify that they should
be allowed access to a network
this requires a single password entered
into each wlan node access points
wireless routers client adapters bridges
as long as the passwords match a client
will be granted access to a wlan
wpa psk pre-shared key mode is designed
for home and small office networks and
doesn't require an authentication server
each wireless network device
authenticates with the access point
using the same 256-bit key generated
from a password or passphrase
wpa and wpa2 enterprise
also referred to as wpa 802.1x mode and
sometimes just wpa as opposed to wpa psk
it is designed for enterprise networks
and requires a radius authentication
server
this requires a more complicated setup
but provides additional security that is
protection against dictionary attacks on
short passwords
802.1
the ieee drafted the 802.1x port-based
network access control standard in 2001
to provide enhanced security for users
of 802.11b wireless lans
it provides port level authentication
for any wired or wireless ethernet
client system
802.11i
ieee 802.11i 2004 or 802.11i implemented
as wpa2
is an amendment to the original ieee
802.11
this standard specifies security
mechanisms for wireless networks
wireless best practices
change the access point's default ssid
disable the broadcast ssid function on
the ap
enable wpa2 for better security
employ mac address filtering
implement a radius or kerberos server to
provide strong authentication
physically locate the ap in an area that
limits its radio emanations
logically put the ap in a dmz with the
firewall between the dmz and the
internal network
implement vpn tunnels
disable dhcp and assign static ip
addresses
penetration test regularly research
migrating to 802.11i technologies
change the access point's default admin
effort to improve the security of the
communication channels hilda jacobs was
asked to provide suggestions for
securing communication
kevin worked with hilda in this
assignment and they produced their
report
the report suggested that all the
site-to-site communication over the
public network or internet should use
ipsec
administrators will have to use ssh
instead of telnet for administration of
network devices or servers over the
network
ssh provides more secure communication
channel as compared to telnet
kevin made notes on the disadvantages of
telnet and added it to his cissp
learning material
what is the major disadvantage of using
telnet
telnet communication is unencrypted and
attacker can easily sniff the data
including now discuss network attacks
following are the various ways a network
can be attacked
dos ddos
a denial of service dos attack is an
attempt on the part of the attacker to
incapacitate a target system or resource
the attack can take one of the two forms
such as high volume and
malfunction high volume attack may
consist of a high volume of traffic that
is designed to incapacitate the target
by causing its resources to become
exhausted
malfunction attack may consist of one or
more specially crafted messages that are
designed to disable the target by
causing its malfunction
teardrop
a teardrop attack is one in which the
attacker sends mangled packet fragments
with overlapping and oversized payloads
to our target system
earlier versions of operating systems
had bugs in the fragment reassembly code
in their tcp drivers that would cause
the system to crash
ping of death
the ping of death pod is an attack on a
system where the attacker sends a ping
packet of length 65 535 bytes to the
target system
the tcp protocol will fragment this
packet as it travels through the network
it is then reassembled on the target
system causing a buffer overflow
sin flood
a sin flood attack is a denial of
service attack in which the attacker
sends a large number of syn packets to
the target system
a sin packet is the first packet in a
tcp connection three-way handshake
by sending a send packet to a system it
allocates resources in memory
sequence number
a sequence number attack consists of an
attacker who attempts to hijack or
disrupt an existing tcp session by
injecting packets that pretend to
originate from one of the two computers
in the session
smurf
a smurf attack consists of a large
number of forged icmp echo requests
the packets are sent to a target
network's broadcast address which causes
all systems on the network to respond
dns poisoning
dns poisoning or dns spoofing or dns
cache poisoning is a computer hacking
attack where the data is introduced into
a domain name system dns name server's
cache database
thus rerouting a request for a web page
and causing the name server to return an
incorrect ip address and diverting
traffic to another computer often the
attackers
a rootkit is a tool or collection of
tools that an attacker can install on a
compromised computer
a rootkit is a stealthy type of
malicious software or malware designed
to hide the existence of certain
processes or programs from normal
methods of detection and enable
continued privileges access to a
computer
worm
a worm is a type of malware that has the
means for automatic self-replication
they spread by exploiting known
vulnerabilities that permit the
malicious program to infect new victims
spam
spam is a common term for unsolicited
commercial email uce
spam greatly adds to the volume of email
traffic on the internet often the volume
of spam is so high that over ninety
percent of all email on the internet is
spam
fishing
phishing is a type of spam where the
content of a message is designed to
masquerade a trustworthy organization
the intention is to defraud the
recipient by persuading them to an
authentic looking website where they
will enter secret information such as
user ids passwords bank account or
credit card numbers date of birth social
insurance numbers and so on
farming
farming is a hacker's attack intended to
redirect a website's traffic to another
bogus site
farming can be conducted either by
changing the host file on a victim's
computer or by exploitation of a
vulnerability in dns server software
ipspoofing attacks
ipaddress spoofing or ipspoofing refers
to the creation of internet protocol ipp
packets with a forged source i p address
the purpose is to conceal the identity
of the sender or impersonating another
computing system
arp poisoning
arp swooping is a computer hacking
technique whereby an attacker sends fake
spoofed address resolution protocol arp
messages onto a local area network
compromising the victim's arp tables
masquerading masquerading as the term
used when one user pretends to be
another user
an attacker socially engineering
passwords from an isp could be an
example of masquerading
let us look at the countermeasures of
network attacks in the following access
control lists
the earliest and the common technique
used to block unwanted traffic is the
use of access control lists acls on
network routers
acls while they may lack the strength to
handle some of the more complex types of
tcp sessions that include the use of
dynamically allocated ports
they often represent a good first line
of defense to block several types of
unwanted traffic
firewalls
firewalls are devices placed at a
network boundary that are designed to
block unwanted incoming or outgoing
traffic
a firewall works by examining each
packet and consulting a list of rules to
determine whether the packet should be
permitted to pass through the firewall
or be blocked
there have been three generations of
firewalls which are packet filters
stateful packet filters and application
layer filters
intrusion detection system ids
intrusion detection systems ids are
programs or devices that are designed to
observe network communications and
generate alerts if any harmful or
malicious traffic is detected
there are two primary types of ids which
are network based ids nids and host
based ids hids
intrusion prevention system ips
an intrusion prevention system ips is a
device or program that not only senses
unwanted traffic but also blocks that
unwanted traffic
there are two primary types of ips which
are network based ips and ips
and host-based ips hips
anti-virus software
anti-virus software that is installed on
servers can detect worms and other
malware and prevent them from installing
private addressing
while the primary purpose of private
addressing was to conserve publicly
routable ip addresses a desirable side
effect is the fact that systems with
private ip addresses are a lot more
difficult to attack
close unnecessary ports and services
a highly effective method to reduce the
probability of successful attack is to
close all unnecessary and unused ports
and services on systems and devices
security patches
all applicable security patches should
be installed on servers and network
devices as soon as it is practical to do
so
unified threat management utm
unified threat management utm is a term
used to describe security devices and
appliances that perform many functions
in order to simplify the defenses in a
network
gateways
a gateway is a general term to join a
system or device that provides some
intermediary or translating function in
a network
routers firewalls and email servers are
some of the examples of gateways
in terms of security countermeasures a
gateway is a system or device that
provides some protection against one or
more threats quick recap of what we have
learned in this domain
the communications and network security
domain involves developing a secure
network architecture and design
securing network components and
communication channels
security can be addressed more
efficiently using the layered approach
the network communication models such as
osi model provide a conceptual framework
for communication between computers
the use of proper countermeasures
provides confidentiality integrity
availability and authentication for
transmissions over private and public
communication networks this concludes
communications and network security
the next domain is identity and access
management